Abby
we have a video to shoot
what yeah I have a job
well that's not living my best life
oh well
at least I'm ready for the day
let's do it she was the OG influencer
the ultimate 2000s party girl the
inventor of the selfie and the seemingly
out of touch with reality reality TV
star of the simple life Once Upon a Time
the world refused to take the hotel
heiress for anything other than a dumb
blod but now a wife and mother at 42
she's finally breaking her Silence about
the extraordinary life of Paris Hilton
and let me tell you it is not what it
has seemed in her brand new Memoir Paris
she exposes the toxic underbelly of her
seemingly pink sparkly privileged not so
simple life following on the heels of
her 2020 YouTube documentary I have
personally been touched and Blown Away
by her transparency and truth so join me
today as we explore the diet of Hotel
royalty and attempt to eat like Paris
Hilton for a day hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
we are back building out some balanced
meals and snacks using the alleged diets
of our favorite celebrities and
influencers as a template for teaching
gentle nutrition and in today's video
I'll be eating in the style of iconic
heiress Paris Hilton with my own twists
based on my own needs also a reminder
that this diet was compiled from primary
and secondary sources so I cannot speak
to its legitimacy or accuracy and this
is what I ate on a random day it should
never be copied or recommended as how
you should eat so always speak to a
dietitian about your unique needs and if
you are new here help a girl out
subscribe to that channel and if you're
on Tick Tock or Instagram you can follow
me at Abby's kitchen Abby let's eat
Paris Hilton may be known for her iconic
catchphrases that's hot modeling career
reality TV show and her skinless sex
tape drama but can't we just take a
minute here to appreciate her remarkable
entrepreneurship especially in the wake
of some horrific teenage trauma and
abuse but also Paris is actually a
foodie like did anyone else watch
cooking with Paris hey guys welcome to
cooking with Paris I actually brought
these so if I was going to cut onions
I would wear them usually I do that when
I cut onions like that was probably the
best Netflix cooking series of all time
sorry Great British Bake Off Paris wins
now despite being literal photogenic
gold to the paparazzi I could not find a
single image of Paris going to her
favorite bougie matcha shop Cha-Cha even
though the owners insist that she
regularly stops by but also now that
she's a mom it is very possible that she
prefers to make it at home at our
website specifically lists and sells
this specific brand called tenzo which
claims long lasting energy without the
crash supporting immune system and
giving you zen-like focus and clarity
can you fact check this Yep this
actually does check out so even though
the caffeine content in matcha is not
that far off of coffee it does tend to
have a more Slow Burn effect thanks to
the amino acid l-theanine which provides
alertness without the crash this is also
partially why it helps promote that
zen-like Focus the combination of
l-theanine caffeine and egcg has been
shown to help enhance mood and cognitive
performance it also helps to support the
immune system thanks to antioxidants
like catechins and flavonols so yes if
you love the taste of matcha there's
really no downsides to a daily cup I'm
not usually a huge matcha Drinker as you
guys know but I figured we go big or we
go home and I ordered myself the most
expensive and bougie matcha latte on my
Uber app
oh look at that cup Celestial you want
to see she's green that's yep that's
that's matcha it's actually not bad
first taste was a little off-putting
because I was definitely expecting
coffee don't know why don't know how but
you know what she's caffeine so
she's good that's
okay but for real your girl is now
hungry so according to our interview
with the list
Paris loves breakfast uh her meal
options range from French toast pancakes
or breakfast sandwich and cereal like
Lucky Charms or Frosted Flakes love us
either with fresh squeezed orange juice
or celery juice when she's trying to be
healthy I'm a lot more excited about the
cereal options than I am up at the
celery juice
but I am happy to hear that we've got
some more exciting options other than
just the standard celebrity acai Bowl my
favorite episode of her cooking show is
when she was hanging with Kim Kardashian
and they made this like like cereal
crusted French toast with lucky charms
on top I love Frosted Flakes so I'm very
excited about this recipe let's do it
okay so just looking at this recipe I
found online it's a pretty standard
looking french toast recipe basically
your eggs your milk we are using
plant-based milk and usually it calls
for like a brioche but I figured we
might as well add a little bit of fiber
here since we are crusting it in
straight up sugar a little bit of
vanilla
a little cinnamon all right I think this
is the technique actually this would be
a good use for all the little broken
bits at the bottom of the bag
Now the recipe as these do usually calls
for a Brio but I figure since we're
crusting it in legitimate just straight
up sugar we could probably add some
Fiber so I got some sourdough which is
my usual bread oh look at that a little
dip dip okay okay I see where this is
going
I see check that out bad boy what what
all right
I don't know I don't know am I talking
to you am I talking too well okay okay
so Frosted Flakes does not exactly pass
my test for daily consumption not unless
we turn into a hunger crushing combo so
let's frap this French toast and turn it
into a balanced meal
so this is either gonna just burden
really fast or it's gonna work we're
gonna see it's actually working
I'm actually surprised I haven't had a
casualty yet
disappointingly I'm gonna skip this
living blue marshmallow fluff situation
on top because the ladies just struggled
so much with that and I do not have the
patience and also I'm too old and I feel
like my teeth just cannot handle that
much sugar first thing in the morning
but come to think of it I'm also kind of
sus about edible glitter now French
toast crusted in cereal probably a
little more sugar than I'm used to
having first thing in the morning so I'm
being very conscious to add a huge
dollop of some full fat Greek yogurt
here we're going to turn this into a
hunger crushing combo and again this is
not dye culture this is just what's
going to feel best to my body and give
me the best staying power to get me to
that next meal oh my gosh so it smells
really good guys
I'm looking
like such color someone so much fun and
I also
version and let's talk about it so we've
got some Fiber in our berries and our
sourdough bread we've got protein the
Greek yogurt and the eggs in the batter
we have healthy fats in the nut butter
on top
ology they're magically delicious and
with all these nutritious add-ins it
just kind of edges out the need to
overdo it on the refined carbs and this
way of eating just kind of feels best to
me
um
damn that's slipping what the is
living
um slaying plus living
equals living it's a thing like look it
up it's the ultimate goal in life
obviously
um
the woman might not know how to load a
dishwasher if it were me in my kitchen
this is when you take the 12 minutes to
clean
you want to put it all in the dishwasher
clean stuff I don't know but she knows
how to make a mean French toast
all right let's talk about lunch so
according to the what Paris eats in a
day exclusive from the list Paris loves
a good baguette sandwich with turkey
cheddar cheese lettuce mayo and mustard
paired with a side of fruit or a
smoothie sounds kind of like my high
school Subway order but probably on way
better bread now I really do not see
anything wrong with having an occasional
deli meat Sammy if that's what brings
you Joy but deli turkey gives me mad dye
culture PTSD of the time when I thought
a baby carrot wrapped in some fat-free
Deli chicory was a sensible snack so I'm
going to go with an equally convenient
rotisserie chicken just because that's
what I have on hand and I basically
always have that on hand and I'm gonna
throw it together a little Sammy so
let's do it all right so I have this
like really yummy sun-dried tomato
ciabatta bread I'm adding some pesto
this is a sun-dried tomato pesto you can
use whatever you like but this is my
favorite so I've got some avocado going
down
all right we'll do some spinach we gotta
like weigh it down a little bit with the
rest of our toppings tomato
because there's not enough tomato
apparently that I like a little juicy
tomato too then I got my rotisserie
chicken
pack that bad boy in
where where and our cheese so I'm using
a provolone because I guess we're going
like with an Italian Vibe I don't know
this is what I have because it's what I
like a little bit of that
this is gonna be a struggle to eat all
right let's put her in a pan I don't
have a panini press but I got another
pot
so we're just gonna go for it
here I need more strength you wouldn't
like me when I'm angry
that's better
all right yeah see that worked super
simple smoothie some Greek yogurt
I have some cauliflower rice
might as well stick some of that in
there
strawberries and raspberries
I've also got some freeze-dried
strawberry powder just to amp up that
strawberry flavor a little pea protein
milk
it looks good
perfect because you gotta coordinate
your smoothie and your outfit obviously
now this is my kind of sandwich we've
got fiber rich carbs in our bread and
our veggies and fruit we've also got
protein in the chicken and the Greek
yogurt and the pea protein milk and some
healthy fats in the avocado plus the
pesto
way better than Subway
um
now that's hot
it's actually cold but you get what I'm
saying
okay so we got some fuel in now it's
time to move according to Vogue Paris
has said that she doesn't usually work
out in real life because quote shopping
is her cardio we love that for her but
unfortunately Mama's on a budget so I'm
gonna like skip that little detail in
her routine but according to this fun
little Tick Tock that she posted during
quarantine in early 2020 entitled eight
easy exercises to stay hot while staying
home love that some of her favorite
moves include lifting designer bags
doing sit-ups with an inflatable unicorn
as a leg rest biking around her mansion
on a pink Leisure bike so cute and
exercising pull-ups in front of a neon
sign that reads need money for Gucci I
mean I suppose that's motivation to stay
fit or at least relevant and in fashion
so in the spirit of this superhuman Eris
let's do a little workout Miss Paris
Hilton Style
[Music]
the best
[Applause]
all right so when it comes to dinner
Paris apparently loves to switch things
up and try different recipes one of her
recent favorites that she taught Kelly
Clarkson to eat is a dish that she calls
living lasagna it's
three different types of cheeses and a
hearty meat sauce with gold flakes on
top for typical Paris bling now I don't
actually eat a lot of beef so I'm gonna
swap in this kind of vegan ground beef
and honestly I would not be surprised if
Paris started to incorporate more
plant-based meals into her diet we've
seen her make a vegan burger and fries
on her cooking show and she recently
invested in a vegan Seafood company
called good catch and since Paris is
known for her love of animals and
basically treating her dogs like her
kids R.I.P Tinkerbell my prediction is
that the world may actually have another
huge celebrity vegan in the years to
come just saying maybe there is no way
Paris is spending hours in the kitchen
making lasagna like a lasagna is like a
three-day process to do it right and you
know I don't do anything half-assed
unless I want to do it half-ass and I
feel like Paris is the same we're crazy
like that so let's simplify and do
things my way we're gonna make a broken
lasagna AKA a lazy ass lasagna the
tastes exactly the saying let's
do it all right if we're gonna make an
authentic vegan broken lasagna I needed
to bring on an authentic vegan Laura
it's my assistant Laura she's gonna help
me make vegan ricotta really yummy and
creamy we can do it we can do it all
right so we need the tofu press oh yeah
so we have a tofu press for those of you
who haven't used a tofu press so simple
just put your tofu in make it fit squish
it all right there we go you just put
the lid on and there's some tension
straps so you're gonna
all the way to the bottom all the way to
the bottom make her tight gotta make
that tofu tight there we go and you can
even flip this up here for some extra
toy do we need the Hulk gloves yes
there we go okay we're good and just
leave it and it will be pressing with
tension and then in a couple minutes you
just drain the water all right I'll call
you in a minute okay bye all right guys
my Spidey son says the water is boiling
so let's make some nudes that's hot
broken all right we're just gonna Heat
this faux meat basically all I'm doing
is gonna just break it apart heat it up
and add in some sauce
so add in some newch extra protein some
B12
okay so we pressed our tofu and now just
take it out of the container I'll help
oh
where's the water the water comes out so
if you hold the container of the thing
oh you just dump it out it's a little
bit of a press this was extra firm so it
wasn't too bad yes yes so um basically
now you just want to take your brick of
tofu
[Music]
come on come on there you go go and just
crumble it up with your hands here you
take just crumble up with your hands it
gets a really great ricotta texture okay
just add different flavorings to give it
more of a realistic flavor all right so
we're gonna add a little onion onion
powder I don't know how much but I'm
just eyeballing that's kind of what I do
I kind of just do an error and then oil
I'm not making much and then cheese yes
this is the best vegan cheese of all
time made by loblas
proudly Canadian a pack or tight yeah
they really do all right so just greet
it in oh wow it's like soft it's
incredible I mean not a lot of vegan
cheese is great so successfully
reconstitute together
mix it in what I would add is probably a
little bit of lemon juice oh yeah we got
that right there just add a little bit
of lemon juice kind of gives it that
Briny yeah yeah yeah yeah tofu is a
blank slate it needs lots of help okay
this looks great we'll put that aside
and we'll build our broken lasagna
thanks Laura
nudes are ready
so to amp up the fiber factor I just
took a zucchini and shaved it with like
a potato peeler just to give the same
kind of consistency as our lasagna nudes
I also threw a little bit of salt on top
to help draw out the excess moisture and
now I'm just basically patting them dry
these will cook in literally two minutes
I don't even like to give them anything
more than that in the pan now we put it
together
bikini down
lasagna nudes ricotta not sure why I use
that accent I've also got some vegan
mozzarella
let that melt and now we toss an attempt
to not get it on ourselves
it looks really good dangerous job I
don't know how Paris pulled this off
with her sliving gloves I do not
understand
mix it
famous
vegan parm look at that it does it's
like super permy
Laura we got to get in here so let's do
a little quick recap here we have
fiberage carbs in our Pasta Plus our
zucchini lots of protein in the vegan
ricotta that we made out of tofu plus
the vegan Ground Round and some healthy
fats in the oil that we used and the nut
based cheeses I'm very excited about
this and it took way less time than an
actual like traditional lasagna let's
get in I am totally slipping this is
amazing it's living the best life yes
it's hot
oh I didn't even chew that I just
swallowed it was yeah it was it's so
good
it tastes like what I buy at the
restaurant look
she's interested in getting in on this
oh my gosh you can slip too Papi you can
slip with us babe let's do this don't
get it on your white coat
what do you think is it slipping
girls day yeah we love it as little
pasta and why night with the girls I'm
Kim K in your Paris okay we can do that
it works it works right I love this all
right let's go load the dishwasher
so if you've watched paris's cooking
show you know the girl loves her glitter
rainbow and unicorns between the fun
fetty flan cake and the Unicorn olies it
really is like a nostalgic Foodies dream
or at least my toddler's ideal menu and
as much as I would love to bake my kids
a rainbow cake today your girl does not
have the energy to bake or clean and my
guess is that now that Paris is also a
mom she probably also cannot that said
I'm all for sprinkles rainbow all the
things and since the world right now is
obsessed with protein ice cream I'm
going to show you the recipe that
literally crashed my blog in the early
days and it is gonna blow your mind okay
so I figured why not make this a little
more fun and colorful and I'm going to
be using some natural dyes in mind
because personally I am sensitive to
artificial food dyes all right unlike
The Tick Tock version which is literally
just cottage cheese mine is a little bit
more balanced and arguably way more
delicious because I add in the frozen
fruit of your choice because I'm going
to add in some colorful birthday cake
cookies at the end so step one add in
your cottage cheese
step two add in your frozen fruit
check that out and because the bananas
are so sweet I personally don't even
think you need added sugar now if you
want to make it extra fun little Galaxy
action a couple drops of some food
coloring I'm gonna do blue
and green
give it a swirl whoa
unicorn
so like I said I'm personally a little
sensitive to food dye so that's why I
avoid them but I love these sprinkles
and these little rainbow cookies because
they are colored naturally with
basically just like fruits and
vegetables you can decorate this however
you'd like it I had a little bit of food
dye just to make it fun for my kids I'm
adding some sprinkles and I'm gonna
crush up some birthday cake cookies on
top
so you can pop this in the freezer if
you like a more firm texture but I
personally like it a little bit softer
more like Froyo and the frozen berries
or fruit makes it just thick enough my
cottage cheese ice cream is not just
straight up protein it's got some Fiber
in the fruit plus some healthy carbs
it's a great post-workout snack and it's
my go-to before bed and birthday cake
anything just hits different hmm
this was like such a super fun day I
mean it was nothing if not Uber colorful
and you know what I always say count
colors not calories we had some super
fun nostalgic Foods balanced out with
very nourishing colorful ingredients and
as parents grows in her maternal role
find strength in her remarkable
resilience and transformation and leaves
behind her trauma response facade I am
so much looking forward to what's in
store and on that note folks I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like to see me
trying next subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
foreign